i mean just [ __ ] like that
will there be another griselda album
hell yeah for sure oh yeah
yeah what was she in gun too i heard i'm
saying i think you want to call it that
what was she
going to do too what was she going to do
too you guys got to have so many [ __ ]
records
just yes we do yes we do hey i want to i
want to i need to drop the me and the
benny and conway project like that's
what really what we need that's what the
fans want that's what the
fans want for real and me and conway we
talked about it before too
you know saying you know [ __ ] got
their obligations and it kind of was
going to get in the middle of the
obligations not saying that we gave a
[ __ ] about that
i would say it's kind of cool you guys
are each independent exactly
like you know i know conway's got a
shady album that's supposed to come out
for the end of the year
but like yo no we're talking about when
we talked when we talked about it then
how many how many songs do you guys have
do you guys like have you guys
officially worked on records for that
project or has it just kind of like
been talked about oh it's been talked
about so you guys haven't like
like i think it should be you conway
and just pick a producer to do the whole
joint whether it's derringer
i think it really should be derringer
just for the fanshawe too i think so if
it's gonna be youtube
it should be darren shirt just do it for
the fans bro yeah we wouldn't have it no
other way that we
of course would do it with derringer and
uh we haven't done that because like
that's a three four day thing you know
how the griselda projects be we get
we get together and we lock the [ __ ]
have you guys talked about a name or
anything
yeah you guys will sell so much [ __ ]
merch when that [ __ ] drops
shout out to conway